about Peter Morrow's arrest well the guy
obviously can't comment on a live police
investigation you would know that but
what I will say is that the SMP has
fully cooperated with the investigation
and it will continue to do so and of
course on the weekend they just passed
my first NEC meeting as party leader we
agreed to carry out a review on
governance on transparency and of course
with some external input too and the
details of that will come forth in the
next few weeks when did you first hear
the news about the arrest and what was
your reaction I was told this morning
after the event and of course my
reaction as you'd imagine much like
anybody involved in the SMP is that this
is a difficulty for the party but again
I've just reiterate and emphasized it's
so important for me not to comment on a
live police investigation and see and be
seen to Prejudice that in any way shape
or form is this the real reason why
Nicholas sturgeon resigned I know I
believe Nicholas dungeon absolutely uh
that you know she had taken the parties
further forward as she possibly could I
think anybody who has particularly seen
Nicola through the covet pandemic could
really sympathize with just how
exhausted she absolutely was
how do you think the public will be
reacting to this news well I think
there'll be concern from the public but
again there is a live police
investigation underway and we will wait
to see what comes at a conclusion of
that police investigation and what does
this mean for the sturgeon Legacy uh
look at Nicholas Sergeant's Legacy
particularly in our own tackling child
poverty and around the promise that she
has made to care experience young
children I think those legacies stand
firming they are foundations that I want
to build upon now of course the police
investigation and the news this morning
is challenging is difficult I'm not
going to pretend otherwise but I'm also
the reason I'm here is to focus on the
priorities of the day and that the
priorities of the Scottish people at
large you've not been an office Bearer
in the SNP but now you are taking on the
leadership of the party labor say
there's been a culture of secrecy and
cover-up are you wanting to get your
hands in the party and just find out
what indeed has been happening well as
you'd imagine one of the early
conversations I had was as Party leaders
with for example our party lawyers and
to understand uh the the the not just
the finances of the party but around
governance and transparency and that's
why in my first meeting as leader of the
NEC on Saturday
was to get the NEC to agree to a course
of action around governance around
transparency with some external input I
think that external input is going to be
really important because people are I do
have questions about the party about
transparency about our finances and I
think we have to reassure our own party
membership as well as a broader Scottish
public
Hamza Yusuf the the new leader of the
SMP responding to the news this morning
that the husband of Nicholas sturgeon
Peter Murrell the former SMP chief
executive has been arrested by police
Scotland over an investigation into the
party's finances in terms of Yusuf